[Music]
the global birth rate is falling in the
UK 900,000 adults last year celebrated
their 50th birthday while 700,000 births
were recorded this is considered to be a
23% deficit or birth Gap in Italy and
Spain it's 55% Japan and South Korea are
set to have one new worker for every
three future retirees what's Behind
These falling rates joining me to
discuss is the spectators Mary Wakefield
and data scientist Steph J Shaw Stephen
and Mary thanks for joining me on
spectator TV Stephen for the magazine
this week you write about the fall in
the global birth rate and you talk about
the Practical and personal impacts of
this Western countries in particular are
facing a huge problem in the future
people have become accustomed to certain
levels of Public Services certain levels
of spending especially as they get older
in terms of their tensions and their
healthare and practically speaking the
way things are going you're going to
have a fewer number of workers who can
provide the cash for those people in
their old
age that's certainly true and I I don't
think we fully realize how much we rely
on current workers to support our aging
our aging population so you know we we
think for example that most St pensions
come from the money that we are paying
into Pension funds as we work for most
countries that's not the case current
people are paying the pensions of the
current retirees and then of course as I
mentioned the whole uh cost of the NHS
in the UK is completely weighted towards
the elderly population so I I don't
think we've yet understood the financial
impact that this is going to have that's
such an important Point Stephen people
assume that they're paying into their
own pots that the money will be there
down the line but these are pay as you
go systems essentially and it it might
be the case that the money isn't there
in the future um in your pce you talk
about some of the policies that
governments have tried to implement to
encourage people to have children but
you note that none of these have been
terribly
successful no um in fact there's
absolutely none that we can say identify
that consistently we see will be
guaranteed to work in fact we can almost
say the exact opposite we can say things
that'll be guaranteed not to work what
we do find is that there are some
short-term increases and those are
usually people who are going to have
children anyway taking advantage of
whatever benefit might be on offer
um so the the issue is really not
directly about a bonness simply to have
a child mothers are having people are
having the children they want to have
it's about the basics it's about having
the core uh surroundings the home the
environment and the right time of life I
guess as well all those things are quite
difficult for uh you know any single
policy to address Mary what do you make
um about this idea of of the
government's job and encouraging people
to have children is that something
government should be doing do you think
it's some something government ever can
meaningfully do I mean I was fascinated
by Steven's piece because um his data
seems to suggest that government can't
incentivize people to have kids so from
my perspective you know you see all
these sort of pro-natalist movements
starting up and conferences and everyone
interested in the baby bust now um and
yet we know from from people like Steven
that it just doesn't work so from my
perspective you need to look at it from
a from another angle which is why ask
yourself first um ask people who wanted
to have children but didn't why that was
the case why didn't they get to have
kids and Mary one of the people making
those points is you you wrote a uh
beautiful and personal column a few
weeks back for The Spectator about your
own experience with motherhood and some
thoughts that you've been reflecting on
can you share those with us yes um I've
got one child who I adore and lavish way
too much attention on
um but looking back on it you know I
would have liked to have had more um so
I was asking myself the question why
didn't I why did I leave it too late um
to have more really and
um it just occurred to me I never
thought that it would be too late no one
had warned me it would be too late that
wasn't um what we were told in school we
were just told about how great sex was
and the important of contraception and
this sort of thing it wasn't in my mind
that it would ever be too late that came
as a shock to me and I wondered really
if Steven had found other women who um
who didn't manage to have kids at Paul
who felt that this was a similar shock
to
them St many many many uh and it's it's
heartbreaking because many of the women
um unlike you Mary ended up with with
with no children at all um so i' I've
I've seen a range of emotions um some
hidden emotions I think because is an
incredibly personal thing but other
delayed emotions where I've met people
after and clearly they had
um you know one one lady explained that
she had um closed her curtains after
watching the documentary I created for
an entire weekend cried her eyes out age
50 I believe and then come to terms
finally with the fact that she wasn't a
mother and she'd never done that before
it was all being held within her so
there are a lot of people who I think
like you are just completely unaware
that they the the body clock and it's
not just the body clock it's the ability
to carry a baby to term and the ability
to have a partner at that right moment I
mean we T to overlook that reality when
we're younger that's the there's just
things that go into having a kid the
partner the fertility and you're not
thinking of all those variables having
to come together no well we don't
prepare young people very well at all
and it's not just about the fertility
when you know we we tell young people I
think rightly to focus on education and
then focus on Career but we don't kind
of tell them that somewhere in the
amongst all of that You' have a few
other things that you might want to be
thinking about like finding the right
partner and planning as to when that
right time might be so and it's a
difficult balance especially for women
it's it's you know it's for me I I I'm
you know very aware that you know I'm a
male in this conversation it's certainly
not the same but hiding this from people
or you know simply ignoring it is it
doesn't benefit anybody Stephen when I
was reading your piece you know what
really jumped out to me is that apart
from big economic shocks which can put
people of having children because of the
financial um implications of that which
which makes a lot of sense there's no
obvious government public policy that's
going to encourage people to to have
more kids you you talk specifically
about finding a partner and I think that
that really jumped out to me because it
it it seemed from your research that
what you were finding um was that um you
say some women maybe aren't aware and
and Mary argues um you know that that
she wasn't really thinking about the
timeline there but there are lots of
women who will be aware of it they'll be
aware from it of it from a very young
age um but are simply struggling to find
that partner to have children with and
and to raise children with it is a huge
undertaking not just Financial but
emotional and personal um can you expand
a little bit on
that yeah well I I I I I empathize with
I think younger people today because I
think in today's environment it's if
anything getting more challenging I
think a general point I would make is
that um it is a general point but I feel
that as people get into their 30s it
gets harder to find that perfect match
when when you're younger um less people
are already in a relationship so
potentially there are more options to
choose from to find someone who you
might want to go on that life Journey
with but as you start to to advance
through life you've probably chosen the
the the town the city the place you want
to live by your 30s you've already got a
friend a friend group you've already
decided where you like to go and
vacation what your hobbies are so you're
narrowing down the specifics of what
person person would match with your
lifestyle rather than creating that life
together so the idea that um it's fine I
I'll find someone when I get to that
moment in time it's not that simple you
know that's my core Point here that
there's always exceptions to this
there's always great stories about
people having children later in life
meeting that partner but those are more
often not the exceptions here I was just
going to ask it might be the same as as
what you're asking K but I was going to
ask about dating apps I was wondering if
I mean I'd never used a I just managed
to miss them which is great as my um but
I wondered if they incentivize men to
look for younger women um because you've
got this great catalog in front of you
you can always say no by the time you do
want to settle
down you know you perhaps you're you're
pushed to pick someone who is s of 25 I
mean 10 years younger than you so women
are being asked women are being told to
settle down later establish your career
but by the time they get to the bloke
the BLS of their generation are perhaps
looking younger is it do you find that
does that sound right I've heard a lot
of stories and most of them are very
challenging about dating apps you know
one fact that we mostly don't know is
that there are far more men on dating
apps than women so for men it's yeah
it's three to one um so for most men on
there you might get you know one
connection uh hit or whatever we call it
these days you know every few months if
you're lucky other men who are maybe the
right height looks Inc are getting
multiple options and that doesn't
benefit men or women because those men
are continually looking at the next
swipe um with little reason to to assume
that today's date is is the one uh women
are getting frustrated I think that
they're not fining meant to settle down
with and there's a whole group of people
who who are not getting any dates at all
so there's a lot of things wrong with
that system Stephen in in some ways what
you and Mary are discussing right now
seems so simple prioritize finding a
partner you know go out there find a
decent person when you're on the younger
side and then you can set up your family
but I think you know for a lot of people
they'll hear that and they'll say well
I've I've been trying to do that or you
know I did pursue that and unfortunately
things didn't work out for me or you'll
have people in their 20s who are now
getting divorced in their 30s and 40s
saying you know I tried and that didn't
work out for me there is no State
solution to this there there is an
element of luck to all of this so what
is the actual prescription that you
would give to people uh when it comes to
addressing this partnership issue in
particular yeah you're right there is an
element of of of luck um in this for for
everyone and we can't change that but we
can increase our chances significantly
if we become more open to the idea men
and women uh once we do find someone who
could be a potential match for a partner
to you know have a family with to be
open to that instead of I think this
idea well let's date for three five
seven years and if everything kind of in
our life fits into place that let's say
at that point because frankly often what
happens is a divorce or the man finds
the 25y old um Etc so it's just being
aware and more open to it will I think
inevitably inevitably increase the
chances for for for many people
Mary well Kate um the only thing that
occurs to me is to if you're looking to
get married and have a family perhaps
think of those qualities in mind with a
partner so you know we're all CH we're
all told to prioritize our life
satisfaction and our pleasure and
happiness and you look for someone who's
sort of super hot or um successful you
know it it sounds funny but someone sort
of kind and dependable or someone you
might want to be a father to your
children is perhaps someone to go for
you know at an earlier age rather than
in a sort of panic later on and in fact
that is what really becomes attractive
after you've been ditched by serial
monogamists for for a while but
yeah Mary um we've explored this in in
the magazine um from from different
angles over the past few years um and I
wonder if we put so much emphasis on
women's understanding of their timeline
and their options understandably so of
course to a degree because it's their
bodies and ultimately they're going to
be the ones getting pregnant um but do
you think we do enough educ for men in
this area to help them to understand
what these timelines realistically look
like and also their own fertility
struggles I mean it is also easier for
men when they're younger uh to to have
children than when they get older it's
not the same by any means um but do you
think sometimes we're disproportionate
in our focus in this conversation surely
it has to be a dialogue between the
Sexes I think mean an ideal world it
would be and in an Ideal World men would
want to have children as much as women
but we I don't think I think that's the
way while biology works and it never has
been you know in my mother's generation
a lot of women you know got pregnant in
order to enforce a marriage in a family
because the guys weren't that into it um
so I just think biologically speaking
practically speaking um the conversation
is most productive when you have it with
women although perhaps you think it
shouldn't be that way um I think it is
could I just add in on the m i mean one
thing dawned on me um that I don't think
too many men think through is that as
they get older if they're single they're
going to be competing with more and more
men for younger and younger women so it
gets harder so the fact that technically
we can become fathers late in life um
unless you are in a quite an exceptional
Lee of you know Hollywood alist or you
know multi-millionaire billionaire your
chances are actually pretty small and
I've seen friends of mine actually into
their 40s who no problem dating in their
30 are suddenly finding they're not
getting those dates
anymore no Stephen you write in the
piece um that you're actually somewhat
optimistic uh when it comes to the
deficit or the birth Gap why is
that um yeah and I didn't expect to be
um during the the documentary itself
really it was
um you know pessimism after pessimism
when you saw the economic challenges the
Social Challenges the
loneliness um
what turned it around to some extent is
the reaction screening the final film to
to younger people have screened it to 12
14 17 year olds through college age
people and the fire in the eyes of those
young people who I think I would
describe often feel anger that that term
has been used at realizing that we us
the adults haven't actually thought this
through you know we're telling them do
your homework study get that you know
education training get on the career
path all of this and I think young
people mostly are assuming that we've
thought this through that that must mean
that in their 30s most likely than not
more likely than not they're going to be
able to have the family that they want
to have when they see people grieving
reality that that didn't happen uh my
finding is only half of women turning 30
without a child ever become a mother and
that's
Global uh so you know I think young
people are going to make decisions there
I mean there's one beautiful statement
I'll share with you from a 21-year-old
young Japanese woman who just quietly
said the documentary changed her life
and she didn't tell me what it meant
what she meant by that but I assumed she
meant she was going to prioritize
finding someone ahead of the other
pressures that Society puts on yeah
certainly young people but certainly
particularly women today and Mary
finally uh on the same point later in
the program I'm speaking to Laura
dodsworth who talks about the death of
chivalry but she's a bit optimistic she
thinks that changes she's seeing changes
in in the younger Generations um are you
seeing some of those changes are you as
optimistic as
Stephen I think so yes I mean I'm
excited by what Stephen says I think
certainly for my generation if you have
if you had kids young um there was a
sort of stigma about that like you
weren't clever or you didn't have a
career option we were also pushed to him
you know and and and that's what I
think's you know got to change um um
because obviously having a kid is
fabulous um so maybe if if that can
change if the stigma drops then I'm I'm
hopeful Stephen and Mary it's nice to
end on an optimistic note thanks for
joining
[Music]
me